we treat our kids like they're are
bonsai trees you know the Bonsai is such
an Exquisite creation of the gardener
The Gardener decides the direction in
which that tree will grow which branches
will be clipped and which will flourish
and the shape of it and um it's a lovely
creation but at the end of the day it is
a possession of the gardener and
something to be oo and odd over and
people can come to the gardener and say
look what you've done aren't you amazing
and it's harmful yeah I think it was in
your Ted Talk where you said they're not
bonsai trees they're wild flowers yeah
you know that's who we humans are yes
there's some rules and regulations we
all need to abide by in order to play
nicely with one another but there's so
much room for variance for difference
each one of us is this unique precious
thing you know I like the poet Mary
Oliver said in one of her poems tell me
what is it you plan to do with this one
wild precious life it is wild it should
be